I love videogames don't we yeah what
game do we have for us today survey
saying I would be this guy because he
has glasses that one we have to work
together this game is all about teamwork
what happened was Trump became president
[ __ ] is that us that's us
why are we so fat is that a giant
meatball is that a giant it's a giant
meatball spaghetti meatball I knew a
Sweden would take over you need to pick
up an ingredient boom alright give me
that give me the lettuce give it a
ladder ASAP one Emmett just put it here
alright my job just cut the lettuce okay
cha cha cha cha cha cha cha
so put that down somewhere else and then
press a in front of that it is Wednesday
in my dudes can you give me the tomato I
will chop the tomato for you might see
it don't worry we made a salad
the most simple dish to a meatball okay
so now the order shows up there and we
don't have that much time give me the
ladies calm down mercy oh my god
come on you gotta feed the meat I'm
already stressed out what are you doing
unacceptable this salad is raw I'm
trying to cut things I am trying to
impress Kevin over here okay mine said
the salad the Beast will not be sir I
was I'm driving this are you driving it
I can drive it too
we're driving it together no no this way
which way this way this way this stuff
okay we're making soup now the pressure
are we making the soup together Marcia
you wanted the onion I will chop the
onions you you don't worry how do you
put it in okay I put one in X you do not
cut onion fast enough what are you doing
you crazy woman okay put the soup there
yeah they're here we're gonna put the
soup in the trash you crazy
the soup is ready to serve matzo give me
the show oh my god we have a fireman's
special thing sorry LM sorry mama Mia
Italian oh you burn that soup I had
bought a ramps it would not be pleased
yeah we make a lot of onion soup it's
the most popular dish I'm trying ten
seconds for the necessary okay okay come
here come here quickly
No damn it damn it
[Music]
we got three okay hey hey yeah you love
go we move back you're running the soup
[ __ ] [ __ ] we're so bad at this come on
stop burning and put it on the frickin
plate don't do the chopping on the chop
suddenly you should be ashamed yeah but
that's your job it's blue I'll do the
dishes you you can you clear why are you
taking the mat oh okay never mind
ah don't worry I got this it happens all
the time
[Music]
great well forever cook now you're gonna
have to run there you've got run run run
and serve that tomato soup go maxi go my
sin yes am i doing why am I here would
you guys like to try set aside sorry I'm
trying to bring in more customers
teamwork it's all the times that we did
good that was good yeah Vega first dish
go what the hell okay
all right you ready you're ready well
it's not finished
there you go go ah yes I hate this job I
hate what do you mean come on we need
three stars I quit come on three stars
we make you Brandes now mates yeah this
ain't no joke
chop the steak into and that were you
gonna chop it first no no no that's not
ready
if you serve you should like that tell
your jacket I'm [ __ ] oh oh okay so it's
take takes a lot of time to make right
so he makes sense that we keep cooking
it all right listen I've worked in the
fast-food business I understand how this
works
[Music]
sorry I didn't know I was dating going
to Ramsay Jesus Christ
[Applause]
[Music]